all right let's close out with something
super fun pulled right from the virtual
pages of Instagram this is what I'm
liking
[Applause]
you see all that's right it's the era of
such distinct and amazing Styles such as
leg warmers off the shoulder oversized
sweatshirts and velcro high tops if
you're super classy well one Connecticut
man has encapsulated some other huge
trends of the 80s in his home so he
redid his newly purchased 1890 Farmhouse
top to bottom with all the pastels
flamingos and palm trees that your heart
can desire he says it's Barbie's dream
house meets Miami 80s Motel meets Golden
Girls and it's simply amazing we have
this Visionary designer on the line
right now watching on NBC4 New York at
three what's up Johnny
Micah hi Kelly how are you oh oh my God
I love your house so in the past two
years you've completely transformed this
home right so take us through the
highlights yeah so my partner and I we
bought our home in the early stages of
the pandemic and girl it needed to glow
up I mean it was spooky I I'm talking
the walls were beige the floors were
beige and so day one of owning the house
I busted out the pink paint and went to
town
um we then started to go to estate sales
and found really cool vintage 80s pieces
and sort of designed each room around
the pieces that we are sourcing for
instance the living room was designed
around the pink couch the kitchen was
designed around the big blue fridge and
the master bedroom was designed around
no other than Miss Piggy herself with
her glamor shot she's the first thing I
see when I wake up in the morning and
she says honey we are going to have a
good day
[Music]
[Applause]
all right and that's not all my man our
season long partner pilot pin makers of
friction the go-to race will pin of the
Kelly Clarkson show want to celebrate
those creating fearlessly and amazingly
so uh just like you so they're giving
you a thousand dollars just for being
you man
are you kidding
well thank you Johnny and thank you to
all our guests today
Kelly Rizzo Isaiah Jude and Ronnie y'all
have a great day and if it's not trying
to change it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]